[Musique]
g
partir
je
/
il
[Musique]
et
rappelle bruno je suis rencontre
syndicale de pire ville au monde a
chargé le temps d'un week end premier
bénéfice est aujourd'hui dix ans 680
personnes dans advance pour fermer la
moitié de deuxième
nous sommes dans un système socio-fiscal
d'une équipe nationale on l'achète maïs
incarne il a pris fin et on revend des
produits intervilles sens large
c'est-à-dire qu'ils rachètent 38 foot en
est un qui fonde le premier aux clients
avec les marges
c'est dans un pays où ces défiscalisées
donc ils se défient ce que de payer les
taxes
olivier la france et en plus ils nous
prennent à la gorge un peu fermé
non les sacs lourds casiers de bière
cobra the animals ou sportivement
puisque les marques se sont fait donc
aujourd'hui on se bat pour sauvegarder
183 emplois
nous avons notre avocat m e villes à
travers le cabinet progexa qui font un
travail de tonnerre pour suspendre et
voire annulés je le plan pinceau pour
rétablir nos emplois à aubenas a quitté
faut savoir que l'amidon un tournant et
10 un déficit de recentralisation c'est
totalement faux et on va le court et est
aujourd'hui on se bat pour greg nous
avons vocation de grève depuis 3h30 ce
matin musical avait pu constater tout le
monde et on soutient à greg
il va sans sanction disciplinaire ce
soir à 16 heures notre directeur manager
notre ambition 15 d'année par la
corporate ait aujourd'hui et arrogant
provocateur il s'est pointé à l'âge et
la cgt pendant que notre ville ait été
présent on pourra dire que les salariés
licenciés une tension est montée au delà
hâtivement convaincu de partir à trois
reprises il a basculé
zhuhai et y'a pas de mots salariés
règles qui s'est levée pour partir de
passion voilà de façon vive
il n'a pas dû de la palud
tu as su qu'il n'y a pas eu de rachaya
pas lancé d'objets ya pas eu d'acte
physique qui n'a même pas tenu bram ii
c'est simplement lui a simplement
demandé de partir
nous avons une vidéo de la preuve zweig
et complètement innocent sur eux et sans
qu'on lui reproche aussi du beau temps
vahidi déjà sanctionné s'applique trois
semaines de mise à pied conservatoire ne
payer juste pour le mans dit de sortir
sage et de la cgt
donc demain jour de transition est là
pour marteler les salariés fois il est
là pour provoquer et alléchant
l'arrogance tu décris une tension
supplémentaire qui a pas une tête
franchement y'a pas lieu d'être qu'on
nous fiche la paix déjà loupé ce que
c'est compliqué et on est là tous deux
legs en soutien qui passe à 16 heures
aujourd'hui on en fait relève temps
qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et